Rob dumansky is a ESPN Packer reporter
joining us from Lambeau what did you
make of Aaron Rodgers comments yesterday
about his knee Rob not surprising Dan I
mean here's the saying look it's not
gonna get better when you're playing 70
snaps against the defense like
Minnesota's I mean it's just you know
you saw him duck out of potential sacks
and he got sacked but he sort of
preemptively took them and I don't mean
like how Brett fire preemptively took
one against Michael Strahan set the
record I mean he was saving his his own
skin that time were multiple times Dan
because he's got to protect that knee
cuz it's not gonna get that okay the
role the Packers play or their doctors
and Rodgers role in deciding how much he
plays if he plays who has the final say
on this well dr. Pat McKenzie who has
sort of become like a household name
because of the collarbone from 2013 the
collarbone from from last year I mean
this this is you know he's done multiple
surgeries on Rogers knee it's a constant
communication like they've got this
gigantic new medical facility across the
street from Lambeau Field anomie Richard
Sherman came here to to have his surgery
like you know it's probably not unusual
to see Aaron Rodgers walking across the
street to go to the D the doctor it's
happened so long my point is though that
they have such a good relationship then
I think they're sorted they're all on
the same page here and trying to get
Rogers a healthy and B protect him from
himself because he's sort of you know I
made the joke about fire but he's sort
of taken on the fire for SONA and that
he wants to play through everything it
killed him last year not to be out there
with the collarbone injury do we know
what the injury is no he first said it
was a sprain which you know our our own
Adam Schefter
reported that it's not a ligament damage
that there's some sort of a compression
injuries it's probably a bone bruise
he's probably stretched out a bunch of
stuff but no mostly Aaron Rodgers Mike
McCarthy and you know probably the
doctors are the only ones that actually
know what it is so the most famous
person in your state and we don't know
what his medical condition is wrong
well you know that's that's how it rolls
around here Dan and you know I guess he
is the most famous person in our state I
had thought of it that way um you know
he said that he's worried it's not gonna
get better but you know can you still I
guess
how does he approach being Aaron Rodgers
he can't be Aaron Rodgers who you know
does whatever he wants so what do you
see what are the modifications you see
with Aaron right I actually just got
done sitting in Michael karthi's office
talking about that very subject and for
a piece I'm writing tomorrow on espn.com
shameless plug
the the idea that he can adapt his game
he might be the most adaptable
quarterback in the NFL I mean yes he's
talented in all these other areas but
the fact that he can basically become a
different quarterback and still you know
be a hundred passer rating guy as a to
use his words a statue just speaks to
how dynamic he is and and that's why
they have a chance to be successful even
if he is half of what he was you know
going into the season went fully healthy
how good is this team well how good is
the defense I think is the question that
needs to be asked because as long as
Rogers is is on the field their offense
is going to be very good you know this
defense once there's such a transition
from Dom Capers to Mike Pettine and
unfortunately like there's been a few
times where it's looked a little bit
more like a capers defense early on I
think people thought everyone was going
to snap their fingers and all of a
sudden we were going to see the Rex Ryan
Mike Pettine defense that dominated when
they were with the Jets and it hasn't
happened yet they're more talented than
the first round pick J or Alexander the
second round pick Josh Jackson two
quarterbacks
are incredibly talented maybe more
talented than any corners that they've
had here the pass rush is lacking and
when they do hit the quarterback they
seems like they get a flag thrown every
time so I'm not sure they know what
they're doing up front in terms of how
they can hit quarterbacks if this was
reversed on the schedule and the Packers
were playing the Vikings this week and
they played the Redskins last week do
you think Rodgers would have played in
game against the Redskins and as opposed
to playing against the division rival
yeah I thought long a lot about that and
what they have said you know they also
have like the bills coming up would they
sit him look I don't think I think if
Aaron Rodgers is medically cleared to
play it's going to take a couple of
300-pound guys to keep him off the field
I mean you'd have to have Brian vlogger
and David Bakhtiari their tackles
physically restrain him from running out
of that tunnel because that's how much
he wants to play I think if he's cleared
he's going to play it doesn't matter if
they're playing Savannah State or the
Minnesota Vikings good stuff Rob we
appreciate it good to visit with you
again it's been too long Dan I was
driving over to Lambeau and here's how
long it's been I didn't even realize you
had your own satellite radio sirius
satellite radio station i am duly
impressed
thank you Ron thank we both accomplished
great things in the last couple of years
thank you Ron
Robb dumansky for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]